in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 10th, on which we commemorate,
the Holy Martyrs, Evlampios and Evlampia. On the 10th of the month,
we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyrs, Evlampios and Evlampia.
Saint Evlampios and Evlampia lived in Nicomedia at the time of the Emperor Maximian.
Together with some other Christians, they took refuge in the mountains near the city
to escape the persecutions that began there in the year 303.
One day, Evlampios came down to buy bread in Nicomedia and saw in the streets
the imperial edicts for the persecution posted on the walls.
He stopped to read them and was seized by some pagans who brought him before the authorities.
Evlampios valiantly confessed his faith before the Emperor himself.
Although by the end of the interrogation, he seemed persuaded to sacrifice and so was taken to the temple.
He went forward as if to sacrifice to Mars, but at his word of command,
the impotent idol fell and broke into pieces on the ground.
The idolaters were enraged to see themselves made fools of and set upon Evlampios with dreadful torments.
As they tortured him, his sister Evlampia came and begged him pray God to let her suffer with him.
The Lord heard her prayer. She was seized and they were both thrown into a cauldron of boiling oil.
God allowed these valiant athletes of Christ to undergo this torment,
only that the breaking forth of his power might be the more evident for the saints emerged completely unharmed.
At this marvel, 200 idolaters believed in Christ.
They were beheaded with Evlampios and Evlampia not long after.
And so they all departed to join the choir of the blessed.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.